Chief Justice John Roberts plays legal
games to strike down another pro-life
law corporations pull back from social
media to avoid political blowback and
covet continues to spike I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show Ben Shapiro
show is sponsored by expressive you can
protect your online privacy today at
express it VPN dot-com slash then a lot
to get to today first there's a lot of
uncertainty out there right now you want
stability especially with your
investments a couple of weeks ago
the Dow dropped 1,700 points in one day
because of fear fear of coronavirus
resurgence and fear from the Fed Lumi
outlook expected spending of 10 trillion
dollars this year to fight the effects
of kovat 19 your grandkids will be
paying for this we're all going to be
paying for this may be paying for it
with an inflated dollar we may be paying
for it with higher taxes bottom line is
it you want to be diversified in your
assets and taking a look at precious
metals would be a smart move right now
in a smart move several months ago you'd
be really really up on your money text
Ben's at 47 47 47 when you purchase on
or before July 31st you get a free
signed copy of my book the right side of
history for my friends over at Birch
gold ask them all your questions they're
the people I trust with precious metals
investing Birch gold we'll go to work
for you and make things super simple
text Ben - 47 47 47 at least request a
free information kit on diversify and go
I always tell you if fully informed
before you spend your money ask all your
questions to my friends over at Birch :
get informed before you invest takes
Ben's who 47 47 47 no obligation Birch
gold has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews a
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau protect your family by protecting
your savings the way I did by investing
in gold with Birch gold group sex Ben -
47 47 47 during the months of June or
July when you open an IRA in precious
metals get a signed copy of my book the
right side of history for free again sex
my name Ben - 47 47 47
we're gonna get to a little bit later on
in the program the Elizabeth Warren
claim that it is time for all of us
become anti-racist I'm gonna explain the
difference between being a not racist
and being an anti-racist in the view of
people or on the left and why it is that
they've perverted the definition of
racism in order to basically suggest
that anyone who doesn't like favorite
leftist policies is in fact a racist
that's what they mean by anti racism or
that's that we will also get to co-ed
where again the gap continues to
increase between the number of
identified cases and the number of
deaths in the United States on a day on
day level the number
deaths by COBIT in the United States
continues to decline or at least remain
steady the idea that we are seeing this
massive increase in death so far is just
not true it is possible that death
increase will happen but one of the
reasons for this the vast proportion of
people who are getting coded at this
point are people who are young and those
people are not dying of kovat the
hospitalization rates are rising they're
not rising so dramatically that they
have overwhelmed the system you would
have expected given the positivity rates
that we've been seeing in states like
California Texas Florida Arizona the
system's already would have been swamped
that in fact is not what is happening
what is happening instead is it a huge
number of people are asymptomatic it is
also possible a lot of people who are
coming in for hospitalizations for other
reasons are being identified with kovat
meaning that they're not coming in esses
airily for koban but you're being
identified as somebody with kovat
because you came in for another reason
and so you're hospitalized with Kovac
even if you're not ICU the real question
is not really hospitalizations so much
as it is I see used we're not at state
where we believe that the ICU is are
going to be overwhelmed in any of the
states as far so we'll get to that in
just a little bit first we begin with
Chief Justice John Roberts so you know I
I hate saying I told you so except that
I love saying I told you so I only hate
saying I told you so
when the thing that I told you so it
turns out to be bad for the country that
thing I told you so about Chief Justice
John Roberts so all the way back all the
way back long ago in the hazy memory of
yesteryear back in 2005 when John
Roberts was selected for the Supreme
Court I and perhaps only I said Chief
Justice John Roberts would not be a good
justice there was no evidence who's
gonna be a good justice he had no record
of textualist or originalist
jurisprudence he was basically just a
guy who's a guy recommended by some
people over at Federalist Society and my
view on judges is very simple if they do
not have a long clear record of
originalism then they should not be put
on the Supreme Court
now the left has a very easy test of its
own which is they just asked
straight-out how their judges are gonna
vote on things right they will just ask
straight out if their judge is gonna
vote to uphold Roe versus Wade or is
going to overturn hell over is DC
they'll just ask these people straight
up these left is honest about its own
justices and what they want from them
they don't want any sort of
interpretation they just run the leftist
policy points people on the right
however
play this game where we can't ask those
questions it's just not civil it's just
not good and if we ask those questions
then maybe Democrats will get mad well I
mean that does show the bad faith of
Democrats because the simple fact of the
matter is
that people like Ruth Bader Ginsburg fly
through the Senate even though it is
perfectly obvious she's going to be a
wild leftist judge same thing with
Justice Sonia Sotomayor same thing with
Elena Kagan it's perfectly obvious that
these people are going to be wildly to
the left and remote Republicans will say
ok yeah but they're qualified so we'll
vote for them anyway whereas if a
Republican if a Justice was appointed by
a Republican or to say yes I think Roe
versus Wade is a badly decided case
immediately done right immediately toast
so what you end up with is a bunch of
quote-unquote stealth candidates from
Republicans
how many Republican justices have turned
out to be failures on it on behalf of
conservatism or originalism or
textualism a lot right John Roberts
would be one too early to Samuel Gore
such an young Gorsuch has large living
nobody was very very bad on that Civil
Rights Act case but you just rewrote
this year we have seen Justice John Paul
Stevens we have seen Justice Sandra Day
O'Connor we have seen a bevy of justices
we've seen a serious number of justices
who's the one I'm thinking of who was
appointed by it was Stevens and sooner
did Justice David Souter appointed by
George HW Bush right there's a whole
list of Republicans who have been
appointing justices and the justices
turn out to be just nebbish as Democrats
hit 100% of the time what is the last
time a Democrat appointed a justice and
the justice ended up being center-right
never the answer is never it never
happened ever it has never happened it
will never happen and the reason for
that is the institutional pressures are
very much for justices to be the people
who reshaped the country from the
top-down there's a lot of pressure to do
that so unless you are somebody like
Clarence Thomas he's already been
through the wars there's a good shot
that you're gonna move well that's what
has happened to Chief Justice John
Roberts so yesterday Chief Justice John
Roberts in an almost unthinkable estupid
decision voted with the left of the
court to rule that a law requiring the
doctors who perform abortions must have
admitting privileges at nearby hospitals
violates abortion rights okay now there
was a case just four years ago it was
basically on the same topic ready but
back in 2016 there was a case in which
Texas had a law law was that if you're
an abortion clinic you have to have
admitting privileges at a hospital the
reason for that is you're doing an
abortion something goes wrong if you
don't have admitting privileges at a
hospital it really gums up the works if
you have some sort of emergency and you
have to rush the person to a hospital so
the rule in Texas was and within a
certain radius you had to have admitting
privileges at that hospital people who
were anti
law said well this restriction this
hurts abortion clinics because abortion
clinics very often can't get admitting
privileges at hospitals nearby
and therefore the abortion clinic would
be put out of business in Louisiana
there's basically apparently one major
abortion clinic and the one major
abortion clinic did not have admitting
privileges at any of the hospitals in a
30-mile radius and so they challenged
the law
hey no here's the thing every surgery
center in Louisiana every surgery center
in Texas has to have admitting
privileges at the local hospital so this
would exempt abortion basically from a
rule that applies to all other surgery
centers and let's be real about this
idea and see which is a early to mid
stage abortion as opposed to an
extraction and dilation which is a late
stage abortion right those those sorts
of surgeries are surgeries are they are
surgeries and so having admitting
privileges is a good thing for that the
notion that this law is patently on its
face a violation of the state's ability
to restrict how medical procedures are
done is of course very very silly okay
so you know he used to feel this way
Chief Justice John Roberts back in 2016
he voted the other way on the Texas law
so there's a five-floor decision in that
case in favor of striking down the Texas
law he wrote a dissent in that case he
sided with the dissenters in that case
he said no no that law from Texas that's
perfectly legal four years later the
exact same law comes up and Chief
Justice John Roberts decides you know
what on behalf of stare decisis I'm just
gonna go along with with with this thing
now started decisis is the idea that a
case has been settled right that we have
sort of a bizarre system in the United
States where we have a common law system
in the judiciary where the judiciary
develops basically its own set of codes
and its own set of laws and it develops
over time the most famous common law
system is of course the British system
is the British don't really have a
constitution per se
and so it really is a body of law made
by judges the United States has a
constitution but then it also has a
common law system derived from that
Constitution via the justices of the
Supreme Court who have created their own
corpus of law okay so the idea there is
that starter decisis the idea that a
case has been decided this was sorry
decisis means it has been decided that
you don't relitigate cases that have
already been litigated now the problem
of course is that nobody actually holds
by starting decisis and started decisis
is basically just an excuse to hold how
you want to hold this is what Justice
Thomas has said is why I've always said
that I like justice Thomas's
jurisprudence
and I like justice scalia's
jurisprudence Justice Scalia paid a lot
of lip service to start her decisis just
as Thomas is like no if the case is
wrong in case is wrong I don't care if
it was decided five years ago or 50
years ago the idea that we're supposed
to uphold the case simply because the
case has been embedded in our national
culture is very stupid and Justice
Thomas is right sorry decisis held then
we'd still be operating under the rule
of Plessy versus Ferguson if sorry
decisis held and we could have never
overturned any of the bad cases in
American history including Dred Scott
liked the idea that that starry decisis
is the deciding factor is obviously very
silly and in fact Justice Roberts
doesn't even believe in stare decisis
depending on the case he has been on the
on the majority side of over tuning of
overturning several long-standing
precedents in the United States well
he's been on the court started as Isis
saying well it's already been decided it
would only apply if you were actually
consistent in your application of stare
decisis but Justice Roberts is purely
not so basically he just decided you
know what I don't wanna have a big
abortion fight something to go along
with the left and that is the guiding
theme every justice order has a guiding
theme the guiding team to justice Robert
says I don't want controversy but I'm
going to create it accidentally because
I don't want controversy that is nearly
every Justice Roberts decision and
nearly every major on Obamacare I don't
want controversy over striking town
Obamacare I don't want to be responsible
for striking down what it's clearly an
unconstitutional law so instead I'm just
gonna say that it is kind of
unconstitutional but I'll rewrite the
law it's now it's magically
constitutional to avoid controversy and
of course now he's plunged face-first
into controversy he did the same thing
yesterday on a consumer finance
Protection Bureau case where he could
have struck down the entire consumer
finance Protection Bureau as an
unconstitutional scheme which it is I'll
explain in a minute I can't but he
didn't instead he split the baby he's
like okay well there's part of it that's
unconstitutional but we'll just rewrite
the law so now it's constitutional and
plunged himself face-first into
controversy this is what he's constantly
doing he's constantly doing things he
voted the wrong way on the Civil Rights
Act case suggesting that transgender
identity and sexual orientation are
protected by the Civil Rights Act of
1964 when clearly they are not he voted
with the majority in that case the only
time he ever votes with his supposed
principles is when he's in the minority
I've yet to see Justice Roberts side
with a controversial
majority decision it really does not
happen where is the swing vote like the
guiding light is you will always take
the side of the left in order to create
institutional stability but
institutional stability inherently means
to the left when four of the members of
the court are on the left and he votes
with the left we're gonna get two more
of this in just a second he's just a
terrible justice he truly is I mean what
a battery by the by the Bush
administration in picking him in the
first place
okay so Chief Justice John Roberts
obviously writes idiotically in this
case I mean it really is incredible it
really is incredible how dumb this
particular decision is from Justice
Roberts so as Dan mcLaughlin properly
writes in National Review Chief Justice
John Roberts lack of courage is damaging
the Supreme Court he says there are
times when it is hard to stand up for
your principles to stand against your
own party or both from judges we are
told the important thing is to follow
not lead to have the ascetic self
discipline to apply the Constitution and
laws as written not to put your own
policy preferences above the letter of
law the right ideas in the right
priorities matter more than character a
good brain beats a good heart a
conservative legal establishment has
long been particularly enamored of this
ideal the umpire calling balls and
strikes which is important but this is
not the first virtue an umpire who can
be cowered by the crowd will not call
the same strike zone for both teams and
that is exactly what Chief Justice John
Roberts said there were two decisions
that came down yesterday one is in a
case called June medical and the other
is in a case called cilia law the June
medical case is the abortion case and
again this is unthinkably stupid what he
did here he voted the other way on the
same case four years ago and now he is
saying that because this case was
decided four years ago and has become
part and parcel of the American
jurisprudence and cannot be overturned
now the basic rule by the way on starter
decisis is longer it's been in place the
more you don't want to overturn it
because there are so many institutions
then built on the decision now that does
not stop the court from stepping in and
overturning hundreds of years of
precedents in America when they have
felt the necessity to do so I mean
you'll recall just a few years ago the
Supreme Court decided on the basis of no
history whatsoever the same-sex marriage
was mandated by the Constitution I mean
the overturning literally not just
centuries of law but millennia of
Western Canon but you know they started
Assizes only matters when the Supreme
Court says it matters as Dan mcLaughlin
says in June medical services llc versus
Rousseau justices Clarence Thomas Samuel
Alito Brett Kavanaugh and Neil Gorsuch
would've upheld that Louisiana law
Chief Justice Roberts sided with the
courts for liberals claiming his hands
were tied by precedent in the 2016 case
whole women's health versus Heller said
the court ruled five three against a
Texas abortion law that required
abortion providers have admitting
at a hospital within 30 miles states
routinely imposed such requirements on
the practice of medicine especially
invasive or surgical procedures as
justice Gorsuch observed in that case
Louisiana law or in this case tracks a
long-standing state laws governing
physicians who perform relatively
low-risk procedures like colonoscopies
lasik eye surgeries and steroid
injections at ambulatory surgical
centers the court in both of these cases
the 2016 case on the Texas law and the
case yesterday on Louisiana law ruled
quote and unnecessary health regulations
that have the purpose or effect of
presenting a substantial obstacle to a
woman seeking an abortion impose in and
do an undue burden on the right to an
abortion but what the court defines is
an unnecessary requirement would be
uncontroversial illegal for any other
medical procedure under the Sun and of
course there is no constitutional right
to abortion it just doesn't exist now
normally if you vote one case four years
ago one way you don't switch and vote
the other way in the exact same case
four years later but Justice Roberts
gave the Liberals the deference they
would not apply themselves writing I
joined the dissent in whole women's
health and continue to believe the case
was wrongly decided the question today
is not whether a whole woman's health
was right or wrong but whether to adhere
to it the legal doctrine of stare
decisis requires us absent special
circumstances to treat like cases alike
except for the fact that the whole
woman's health decision overturned a
prior decision that had already said the
opposite right the the four liberals
allowed to do over in the whole women's
health case Justice Alito pointed out
that the whole woman's health decision
disregarded basic rules and apply in all
other cases
sorry decisis is supposed to promote
stability in law by adhering to
consistent and predictable rules but the
opinions striking down Louisiana law
didn't do any of that stuff
Robertson joined the majority opinion
which is written by Justice Breyer but
by joining its outcome he prevented the
courts conservatives from doing anything
to keep the court I'm constantly
rewriting its own rules this is the
point that is being made here by Zandt
McLaughlin and National Review abortion
law is governed by a 1992 decision while
Planned Parenthood versus Casey one of
the worst cases in Supreme Court history
in which the court declared that people
have a right to define the world and the
universe for themselves I mean I'm not
kidding that's actually the language of
the decision as Roberts noted Casey asks
whether an abortion law imposes an undue
burden for the court in whole woman's
health and the plurality today changed
the rule to make it a ban
test that reviews the pros and cons of
the law roberts reiterated that whole
women's health
therefore departs from casey and asks
the court to apply a test they are not
competent to administer this is again in
Roberts's opinion quote in this context
courts applying a balancing test would
be asked in essence to weigh the state's
interests in protecting the potentiality
of human life and the health of the
woman on one hand against the woman's
liberty interest in defining her own
concept of existence of meaning of the
universe and of the mystery of human
life on the other and that is that that
quote is from planned pethood versus
case that's quite i was referring to
which is just idiotic
there's no plausible sense in which
anyone let alone this court could
objectively assign weights to such
imponderable values at no meaningful way
to compare them if there were attempting
to do so would be like judging whether a
particular line is longer than a
particular rock is heavy that's what
justice Ansel and Antonin Scalia said in
Planned Parenthood versus KC pretending
we could pull that off would require us
to act as legislators not judges we have
explained the traditional rule that
state and federal legislatures have wide
discretion to pass legislation in areas
where there is medical and scientific
uncertainty is consistent with cacey
right that that last line is pretty
poignant okay but roberts joined the
majority opinion he joined the majority
opinion and which was insane they
basically demolished the majority
opinion and then he joined the majority
opinion which is crazy which is crazy
town's okay that is one thing that
roberts said yesterday he ruled in a
second case in which he saved the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau so
for those who don't know the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau was a piece
of government machinery created
independent of the executive branch of
the government the head of the CFPB
could not be fired their basic idea they
were empowered with overwhelming powers
incredible powers I talked about on the
program before incredible powers to
oversee business in the United States
and find businesses and investigate
businesses and the head of it was not
answerable to the executive branch which
means that it violates the separation of
powers because you either work for the
legislature or you work for the
executive or you work for the judiciary
there is no unaccountable fourth branch
of government the CFPB set up the head
of the CFPB so the person could not be
fired okay so the this comes up before
the court and what if the court sue they
uphold the presence of the CFPB by
basically saying okay you know what we
understand the head can't be fired but
just because the head can't be fired
doesn't mean that we can't make them
fireable by the president so we're just
gonna rewrite the law wholesale so
basically the same thing that that
Roberts did in Obamacare where he
declared
that a tax was that that was actually a
that a fee was actually attacked right
he just rewrote the law
in order to say it was he did the exact
same thing yesterday joining a 5-4
majority as Dan mcLaughlin says in the
second case Celia law versus Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau the Chief
Justice wrote the court's opinion
declaring that Congress in the 2010
dodd-frank act had violated the
separation of powers by placing the
CFPB's head beyond the reach of
presidents to remove at will it's an
epic embarrassment for Elizabeth Warren
who designed the CFPB and for President
Obama but Roberts pulled up short of
concluding that an agency created in
violation of the Constitution lacked the
power to compel the citizenry so they
could go ahead and continue operating as
normal we're just gonna make the person
fireball by the president if Congress
passes an unconstitutional statute
generally you strike it down unless
there is a separable 'ti provision right
severability provision is a provision in
the law that says you can carve off this
portion of the law and you can declare
it invalid and if you do that then
here's our back-up plan Congress didn't
do any of that so Roberts just did it
for them Roberts just said okay fine you
know what we're just gonna make this
person fireable by the president and
then we'll just preserve the law so
Roberts is just doing the work of the
left at this point now Dan McLaughlin is
more charitable he says it's a mistake
to compare Roberts to past Republican
appointees because unlike William
Brennan or John Paul Stevens or Souter
or Earl Warren burgers or O'Connor he
actually is good at his job he's just
weak but I don't actually buy that week
is week is still left okay if you wrote
with the left you're with the left okay
there is no kind of halfway point here
so once again what this demonstrates is
that if you are relying on the
Republican Party to save you by
appointing Supreme Court justices who
are on the right Supreme Court justices
can help a little bit can they
overwhelmingly preserve your rights
no and Republicans are simply not
willing to appoint the kind of people
who will preserve your rights by asking
in the honest and open questions they
need to be asked before they are
appointed to the Supreme Court it's more
of this in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that the Second
Amendment pretty important right now
so we've got an entire class of people
in the United States who have decided
that it's time to defund the police and
then they've also decided that it's time
for you not to have a gun no meeven
police should have guns well that seems
like a very very terrible idea there's a
reason that shootings are spiking in
major cities around the United States
and that's a pretty damn good reason for
you to be armed you know who believes in
the
Bravo Company USA Bravo Company
manufacturing build a professional-grade
product built to combat standards that's
because BCM believes the same level of
protection should be provided to every
American regardless if they're a private
citizen or a professional the people of
ECM assume that when a rifle leaves
their shop it will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or a
soldier overseas and with that in mind
every component of BCM rifle is hand
assembled and tested by Americans
the people of BCM feel it is their moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
the tools that will not fail the end
user when it's not just a paper target
but somebody coming to do them harm BCM
also knows that making reliable life
saving tools is only half the story
the company also works with leading
instructors of marksmanship from top
levels of Americas at Special Ops forces
from Marine Corps force reconnaissance
to US Army Special Operations Forces
connecting them with other Americans
these top instructors will teach you the
skills necessary to defend yourself your
family or others if you're trying to
protect yourself having a gun that works
is definitely a really important
important thing protecting your rights
learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing today head on over to my
friends at Bravo Company MFG comm you
can discover more about their products
special offers and upcoming news that is
Bravo Company MFG comm if you want to
see even more about them check them out
at youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA
macho dude standing up for American
rights go check them out Bravo Company
USA go check them out right now Bravo
Company MFG dot-com okay so now bottom
line is with with Justice Roberts like
so much of the rest of the court if
you're unwilling to stand up for the
right principles then those principles
we pulled away right in front of you and
it does underscore there's something I
talked about it but brand-new book
coming out called how to destroy America
in three easy steps and I talked about a
couple of different things in the book I
talk about our philosophy of Rights by
the philosophy that Springs from the
Declaration of Independence and is
encoded in the Constitution I talked
about that but well I say it's not
enough to have a philosophy of rights
because the fact is you can't rely on
legality to save you it's important that
a country have a culture of rights what
I mean by that is that we all in our
daily lives rely on each other to
respect our rights to do things right we
have to have enough
have enough respect for our neighbors
that we allow our neighbors to do things
that are within their rights even if we
disagree with them and that is something
that is falling away incredibly quickly
in the United States and here's the
thing the Supreme Court and the law tend
to follow the culture so if the culture
becomes incredibly censorious if the
culture decides that certain types of
speech are no longer allowed it is only
a matter of time before their justices
on the Supreme Court Appointed
presumably by a Democrat or a weak-kneed
Republican and those justices start
maintaining that for example hate speech
regulations don't violate the First
Amendment's of the United States
Constitution it is only a matter of time
until that happens and it's gonna be
called wild and crazy to say such things
but the reality is we've had such laws
promulgated in states across the United
States on college campuses right there
there are all sorts of regulations on
college campuses that patently offend
the First Amendment and that have been
at the very least sort of overlooked by
court systems in foreign countries like
the UK or Canada there are hate speech
regulations on the books and you are
seeing increasingly a push for such sort
of regulations in the United States now
that will follow a cultural push to cast
out everybody who disagrees with you
the entire model of free speech of
liberal free speech
I mean classical liberal free speech is
the idea that a marketplace of ideas a
good thing typically you want people to
be able to speak their minds even if
what they are saying offends you even if
what they are saying is wrong or
incorrect better too much speech than
too little speech that is the culture of
rights I'm talking about the recognition
that the ACLU is old recognition that I
hate what you're saying but I will fight
and die for your right to say it is
there anybody who believes that members
of the Democratic Party would do that
today is there anybody who believes that
members of today's culture today
censorious culture would fight and die
for the right of somebody else to say
something with which they disagree more
likely they would kill somebody who is
who's disagreeing at least figuratively
speaking at least they would excise them
from the American body politic the
culture of Rights is falling away and
it's falling away in a variety of ways
he's following away particularly when it
comes to the consumption of products
it's really interesting to see which
avenues the fight against a culture of
free speech rights he's moving so
they're going in through the most
vulnerable targets that the hard left
that is seeking to restrict the ability
to perform free speech in America is
going after the most vulnerable targets
you wonder why they go after college
campuses where by the way there is less
offensive speech on college campuses
than anywhere else in American life at
least if you're on the American left
around the American left these are safe
spaces for you the idea that you're
experiencing massive overwhelming
discrimination racism brutal right-wing
bigotry on college campuses is insane
but those are always ground zero for
these sorts of controversies why because
you push where there's much in the words
of Stalin right you always make sure
that you're going to find the people who
are most likely to cave to you and
that's the people you target so where
does this manifest first it manifest
first on college campuses where hate
speech regulations are promulgated and
where you see college administrators
bowing to the whims of a mob and
declaring that people who say perfectly
inoffensive things ought to be cast out
of their jobs right this is how you get
Brett Weinstein getting tossed out of
his job over at Evergreen State College
for the great crime was saying I'm not
gonna stop teaching today just because
of the color of my skin that's literally
a thing that happened at Evergreen State
College but so it starts at college
campuses it then moves into the media
because all of these college graduates
then go work at the New York Times and
then they get the op-ed editor of the
New York Times thrown out of his job for
the grave sin of running an editorial
from a sitting united state senator
suggesting that perhaps federal troops
might have to be used if ongoing riots
in American cities are not quelled
which is a majority proposition in the
but the idea is that's threatening and
it's bad so all of the and the media
because the media are left and
apologetic about America's culture of
rights because America's culture of
rights according to the American Left
rests on a fundamental basis of bigotry
and evil because of all of that a
culture of rights has to be done away
with the only way we can achieve true
equality is by quashing the culture of
Rights and replacing it with a culture
of mandatory tolerance and acceptance of
one type of point of view right a
repressive tolerance as Herbert Marcuse
suggested in the 1960s a tolerance of
only certain points of view that forward
the left-wing perspective on what utopia
should look like so it starts on college
campuses and then it moves over to the
media and now it's moving into the
corporate world I'm gonna claim that in
just one second first let us talk about
the simple fact that if you run a
business if you own a business you gotta
know your numbers I mean right now with
the economy as volatile as the economy
all over the place it is incredibly
important that you know in granular
detail every aspect of your business you
got to be on top of your data what do
you need to make that happen in
integrated business solution that
integrated business solution NetSuite by
Oracle it's the world's number one cloud
business system finance HR inventory
e-commerce everything you need all in
one place
you say time you save money save
headaches whether you're doing a million
or hundreds of millions in sales
NetSuite will give you visibility and
control so you can manage every penny
with precision join over 20,000
companies who trust NetSuite to go
faster with confidence
NetSuite surveyed hundreds of business
leaders and assemble the PlayBook of the
top strategies they are using as America
reopens for business receive your free
guide seven actions businesses need to
take right now schedule your free
product tour and NetSuite comm slash
Shapiro again that's NetSuite calm it /
- girl get that free guide schedule your
free product tool right now at NetSuite
calm / rapira NEETs uit EECOM / repair
integrate all that business data make
sure that you are on top of everything
you need to know about your business to
keep it running and functioning at full
force
NetSuite calm / Shapiro for that free
guide and the free product tour right
now and so you left to push against our
culture of rights not just the push
against legal rights which will come
later they push against the culture of
rights turning institutions into batons
to wield against political opponents and
casting out political opponents who are
well within their rights and speaking
out right that that culture is important
culture matters hey the idea that the
only things the amount you hear this
from the left very often why are you
conservative
planning so much about private
institutions doing what they're doing
okay number one they have a right to do
it and number two they could be very
wrong and it can be very dangerous when
all the institutions start to mirror in
anti-freedom point of view that is a
dangerous thing it is a bad thing it
doesn't mean that these institutions
should be regulated by the government
that's an imposition on freedom too but
you can but you can also be contributing
the decline of a of a certain level of
understanding that there will be
different points of view in American
public life and it's horrible for the
culture and the quarter the culture
absolutely matters the same left it
claims that the right can't care about
the culture cares almost nothing about
the law and everything about the culture
it's been all day trying to pervert the
instruments of culture to their
political point of view it's why the
left is so focused on painting black
lives matter on the side of the NBA
basketball court yeah because the
culture matters right there they're
attempting to change hearts and minds on
a particular issue well when you have
entire systems in America institutions
in America that are now dedicated to the
proposition that certain types of speech
should not be allowed well that's gonna
have a pretty predictable impact and how
Americans see the institution of free
speech on a legal level and also just on
a general level because if you can't
tolerate your neighbors saying something
you disagree with we can't be friends
anymore this is what the left is pushing
by the way you can't speak to your
parents unless they now the words black
lives matter with just the precise
amount of authenticity well then that
that's a culture war that actually has
dramatic impact for how people live it's
not just the law it's the culture the
matters in the United States I mean this
is why I talk about again three things
in America that you actually need to be
unified and how to destroy America in
three easy steps philosophy and history
a shared history and a shared culture
and all three are under attack right now
the philosophy is under attack because
the idea is the declaration is banned
the Constitution is bad and founded in
racism steeped in evil the culture is
bad because again the culture is drawn
from a well of white supremacy and the
history is bad because the history is
replete with discrimination and bias and
bigotry and evil right that is the case
of the left and that results in an anti
freedom culture that is what the left is
pushing right now all in the name of
tolerance and acceptance and that is
what the left is is pushing very hard
right now and the what so they started
off as I've said they started off on
college campuses pushing the
administration's on college campuses to
shut down people's ability to speak
freely and declaring that we'd have free
speech zones and that we would ensure
that everybody was in
their safe space where they were free
from microaggressions and we'll teach
all the white students about the fact
that they're not allowed to say things
like I am colorblind because that is in
and of itself is racist right you're not
allowed to ask where somebody is from
because that could be micro aggressing
all that started on college campuses
then it moved into the halls of the
media because the media is a very left
institution and the heads of the media
are just ashamed enough of America
they're more ashamed of America and
America's history and America's
philosophy they're more ashamed of that
and they are attached to the notion of
everybody should be speaking freely and
more speeches better speech and they're
more attached to certain principles than
other principles and now it has moved on
to corporate America and the reason it's
moved on to corporate America is begun
because again corporate America is a
soft target you're running a corporation
the corporation has one goal to sell
coke right that you're the head of
coca-cola corporation all you do all day
is figure out how to sell coke to people
and normally you just advertise where
the people are right they're a bunch of
different platforms they're a bunch of
different places that you can advertise
coke and frankly you don't really care
right you're putting up billboards you
just want to see what the ROI is what is
the return on investment well let's say
that you're getting a pretty solid
return on investment by advertising for
example on Facebook and then let's say
that there are a loud coterie of people
who say we are going to launch a
campaign against you
coca-cola for the crime of for the great
evil of having you advertised on
Facebook and we're gonna launch a
boycott against coca-cola now you have
two choices one is you can say okay go
for it right enjoy because it turns out
the benefit we get from advertising on
Facebook outweighs the down the downside
of you guys being angry at us for
advertising on Facebook now in reality
that is the reality okay the reality is
boycotts Barrett barely ever virtually
never work boycotts are usually
ineffective but right now people at
coca-cola are thinking okay well we have
a second front battle it is not merely a
calculation of do we get more out of
advertising on Facebook and we then we
get a downside from people yelling at us
it is we have a bunch of staffers and
our staffers are yelling at us
internally and our staffers are telling
us that we're racist if we don't take
our stuff down from Facebook now we
haven't advertised done anything racist
we have not gone out and advertised the
most Farrakhan's trumpet call whatever
the hell is stupid newspaper is we've
not advertised with David Duke we're
advertising on a social media platform
with billions
that's literally all we're doing but it
doesn't matter because the idea is I can
find other alternative ways of
advertising that appeal to the woke base
inside our own company and don't offend
the media and don't give us a ten
million dollars with bad media coverage
it makes my job easier makes my days
you're all I have to do is click this
button if I click this button right here
and I temporarily suspend ads from
Facebook how much cocoa really sell it
off of Facebook anyway is it worth the
hassle maybe we can find other ways of
doing this maybe we can find other ways
of doing this that adhere to the anti
rights culture that is being promulgated
by the left because remember when people
advertise on Facebook there's actually
what's happening right now when when
people advertise on Facebook or Twitter
or any of the other social media
platforms they are not endorsing the
messages that are there
this is incredibly silly everybody knows
this by the way when people advertise on
Fox News they're not endorsing
everything on Fox News any more than if
they advertise on MSNBC they're
endorsing everything on MSNBC when
products advertise themselves typically
they're advertising because they wish to
reach the audience not because they
subsidized a Tucker Carlson script that
day okay none of them are privy to
Tucker Carlson script that day but what
the left is attempting to do right now
is basically remove all profit incentive
for corporations to back free speech and
therefore to remove the profit incentive
for an entire free speech industry that
exists to provide opposing points of
view and then the only points of view
that will be left are the points of view
had preceded his brand-new era of
Internet freedom right because what the
internet really did is it decentralized
the power mechanisms for dissemination
of information that's what the internet
did mime at Raj was very instrumental in
this when Matt Drudge created Drudge
Report and suddenly people were flocking
to Drudge Report to get reporting from
an institution outside the mainstream
media it broke the media's monopoly on
this so many members of the media people
at the New York Times will cheer on eg
monetization of free speech content over
on Facebook it will cheer on Facebook as
Facebook restricts
material or is Twitter restrictions here
at Facebook's been better than the
others by the way this one's been way
better than the others he's ELISA Oberg
has a baseline adherence the levels of a
belief in free speech according to his
own speeches at Georgetown but there are
lots of other places that are saying
okay well we'll just go listen we can
still put out the New York Times
basically here's what happened the New
York Times Washington Post ABC NBC CBS
all the mainstream media outlets used to
have monopolies the monopoly was broken
by the internet and advertisers
recognize that there are big audiences
that cropped up for these alternative
mechanisms and so they started
advertising on those mechanisms and so
the media the old the old world media he
mainstream media in combination with a
censorious left decided they were going
to reestablish the monopoly by basically
taking all these social media mechanisms
and having the social media mechanisms
become merely loudspeakers for the
mainstream media while banning everybody
else right that's the actual goal here
and all they have to do is intimidate
the corporation's into stopping their
advertisements on these social media
platforms that's all they have to do
remove the profit margins for all of
these smaller publishers all they have
to do is make sure that views they don't
like are taken out of the realm of
Commerce and corporations think to
themselves okay do I really want this
fight is it like if you're a corporate
middle manager in marketing do you
really want to spend your day being
inundated with emails from supposedly
angry people who are on a listserv
is that something that you want to do
you want to find yourself cancelled
tomorrow because remember all of these
corporations are made up of individuals
and you're the middle manager who's
approving the Facebook ad buy and
suddenly somebody is resurfacing a tweet
he wrote 25 years ago a face but some
post on social media your high school
yearbook is coming out you don't want to
be on the front lines that thing you'd
prefer to have an easy life where you
can be left alone the left knows this
and to the left is attacking the culture
of rights by going after the corporation
so when colleges then when media and now
it's going corporations and so what this
means is that you are seeing for example
Starbucks being the latest company to
posit advertising across social media
platforms across all of them coke said
would pause advertising on all social
media platforms globally Unilever is
halting advertising on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter in the United
States through December 31st
according to Starbucks we believe in
bringing communities together both in
person and online and we stand against
hate speech now nobody suggested that
Starbucks stood in favor of hate speech
but who the hell is Starbucks to
determine what a social media platform
should be they're not advertising on any
of the hate speech stuff and if they
found out they were they would pull
their advertising from that stuff but
instead of saying okay YouTube or
Facebook you know there's some bad stuff
there and we don't want to be associated
with that bad stuff they say we're just
not gonna be involved in free speech at
all and until Facebook only has content
that we feel comfortable advertising on
then we are not going to be on Facebook
in other words we are run by the woke
it's the woke now run the outlook on
rights at the corporations and then the
outlook on rights at the corporation's
dictates their spending which dictates
their attempting that dictates the rules
at these social media companies that is
the chain of logic here and is really
really dangerous the company said we
believe in bringing communities online
we stand against hate speech we believe
more must be done to create welcoming
and inclusive online communities we
believe both business leaders and policy
makers need to come together to affect
real change and so the reason that all
of these places are doing this and again
it is Facebook Instagram it's whether
it's basically all of them they said
they're not going to include YouTube
Starbucks why aren't they going to
include YouTube the reason they're not
going to include YouTube is because they
decided it's too lucrative to advertise
on YouTube that's the reality right
Starbucks decided that sure we're
against all this hate speech stuff and
and yeah but I'm sure there's a lot of
bad videos on YouTube but you know what
I mean really we still make more money
on YouTube so we're just gonna we're
gonna stick with small YouTube thing
Starbucks said though is pausing
advertising it isn't joining me stop
hate for-profit boycott campaign which
kicked off earlier this month after a
group of organizations called on
Facebook advertisers to pause their ads
Spencer in July more than a hundred
marketers including Levi's Patagonia REI
Lending Club at North Face have
announced their intentions to join
according to a running list from
sleeping giants which is one of the
worst groups on the Internet
sleeping giants is basically just a
boycott group directed against the right
and it's not just the radical right it's
like everybody on the right if you are
to the right of Karl Marx sleeping
giants would love to see you
D monetize right that is their goal a
group of organizations includes
anti-defamation league the n-double-a-cp
sleeping giants Color of Change which is
like almost a radical socialist group
Free Press and common sense right so
again the idea here is they're gonna
create a lot of bad press for
corporations for corporations cave and
then social media companies cave
and then one social media companies cave
and they start banning people left and
right in order to get the money back
then what happens is when you have
institutional captcha right when
corporations are captured by the world
left
the impact is going to be social media
companies end up being captured by the
world left when the social media
companies are captured by the world left
and presumably there will be basically
no method for dissemination of
information that counters the prevailing
left-wing narrative in the culture this
is dangerous stuff it is bad for the
country and it leads by the way to
exactly the silos and echo chambers the
left is constantly whining about
let's constantly say well you know
there's daily wire and that's mostly
right when people who watch that I mean
that's a silo it's a silo of information
they don't believe what we believe who
do you think created those silos who do
you think is exacerbating those silos
and I'm perfectly willing on my Sunday
special to have on anybody from the left
the number of people on the Left who
invited me on their podcast for a nice
genuine conversation can be numbered on
one hand he literally will not do it and
they will not do it because they're
afraid of blowback from their own
community
I've had conversations with the biggest
podcasters unless literally the biggest
and I've said why don't we have a
crossover package nope can't do it our
people would kill us
right this is the culture of rights that
is being destroyed right now and it is
being destroyed on the basis of why and
that lies that rights are an outgrowth
of evil right are an outgrowth of white
supremacy we're gonna get to that
argument which is now being made by none
other than Elizabeth Warren possible
president and VP pick four for Joe Biden
and get to that in a second first what
do millions of Americans and three
former US presidents have in common they
all agree that bull and branch eats are
the softest most comfortable pure
organic cotton sheets on earth by the
way I agree also these sheets are
unbelievable they are so comfortable
we're never gonna be able to sleep on
other sheets again I mean that's how
good they are and yeah they are a they
are not going to cost you 20 bucks at
the local retail outlet store because
it's tough you get for 20 bucks at the
local retail outlets or socks it's a
tarp okay the stuff that you're getting
from Boleyn branch is the highest
quality it's amazing it's rain-fed
pesticide free the cotton tear is the
highest organic certification which is
why it's so soft because they work with
family-owned mills all over the world to
expertly weave every set bull and branch
eats with the highest level of
craftsmanship it is quality you can feel
the moment you open the box and you're
spending hours every day on those sheets
and they are just you want them to be
great one brand sheets again they're so
good I literally cannot sleep on non
Boleyn branch eats that's how they're
there oh and branch sheets start at just
160 dollars plus there are a thousand
dollar quality for a fraction of the
price I mean they really are you can
sleep on them for a month risk-free so
if you don't even like them and send
them back right now you had 50 bucks off
any sheet set at bull and branch calm
with promo code Bennett Shapiro so Bo ll
and branch comm from Oakland Ben Shapiro
for 50 bucks off Boleyn branch calm
promo code Ben Shapiro restrictions may
apply see bull and branch calm for
details go check them out right now okay
we can get to the censorious culture and
the outcome of this and where it is
coming from right what is the new
philosophy that is backing the culture
of censorship that is now being caved
into by corporations
we'll get to that in just one second
first if you're not already a daily
where a member should consider getting a
reader's pass to Daily wire calm it is a
great value for only 3 bucks a month
when you sign up you get that first
month for only 99 cents you also get
access to our mobile app articles ad
free access to exclusive editorials like
a really important one I've got out
right now over its daily we're 11 left
to Smith's about American history go
check that out but only if you are a
subscriber if you haven't checked out
the readers pass already head on over to
daily wear it icon sign up for just a
dollar and again make sure that you go
pick up a copy of the book that I've
been talking about it's not coming out
till July 21st she sold a little bit of
time to pre-order but it is why I mean
it is flying I mean let's just say that
this book is gonna sell it's gonna sell
out very very quickly go check out daily
wire.com
slash Ben it's a pitch to pre-order my
book how to destroy America in three
easy steps which is the topic of the day
I mean that is what is happening go
check it out right now daily we're calm
spending listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say the so-called free speech
platforms are now banning all outlandish
speech out all outline speech reddit is
gonna ban the Donald read which is one
of the bigger threads on Reddit it's it
really is a huge thread on reddit and
then just to make it fair they're also
banning chapo traphouse which is the
socialist kind of mud bros over there I
mean they're really they get in the mud
they're really gross and really ugly but
you know they have a rights of free
speech to something they would never say
about me but chapo traphouse has a right
to basically say what they want but
apparently their threat has been shut
down too
they shut down 2000 communities today
after updating their content policy to
more explicitly ban hate speech the
policy up take him three weeks after
black lives matter protests led several
popular reddit forms to go dark
temporarily in protest of what they
called the company's laxed policies
around hosting and promoting racist
content
so now reddit has decided that they are
going to continue to crack down on the
ability of others to speak I mean the
reddit CEO Steve Huffman said quote I
have to admit I've struggled about
balancing my values as an American and
around free speech and free expression
with my values and the company's values
around common human decency ah so this
is where the rubber meets the road
here's the reality there is an Overton
Window right these corporations are not
the government but they are allowed to
have certain limits as to what they will
allow but if your belief in common
decency is basically you just agree with
the policy preferences have left if
common decency means you agree with the
left and that is what is coming into
conflict with free speech and free
expression and free speech and free
expression are no longer existent again
the rule should be unless it is
something that if I were running a
corporation right like a free speech
corporation not ideologically driven one
that is purely mine like daily water if
I were running a platform like Reddit my
rule would be unless you are violative
of law unless you are violative of open
like straight abuse then you get to stay
on and you can say ugly things you can
say terrible things because guess what
that is the world we live in and you
have to trust at some point that people
are going to rise above that even if
they see that content there's also this
basic notion out there that if you ever
see a bad piece of content on the
internet you are forever scarred it's
absolute crap okay I've seen more bad
content about me and my family on the
Internet probably any living human being
okay and I can promise you you're not
permanently scarred by this stuff you're
fine you're gonna be okay generally
speaking you will be okay
speaking of somebody who again has
received probably more hatred online and
nearly any other living human being on
planet earth but that that statement
says it all so the question of course is
how do to find your common human decency
and from the left common human decency
means agree with us so if it's agree
with us and we're after balance agree
with us and free speech agree with us
inherently says no free speech agree
with us and you must agree with us is
exactly the repressive tolerance I've
mentioned it earlier on the show a lot
philosophy professor from the from the
so-called Frankfurt School of philosophy
sort of a Marxist school of belief named
Herbert Marcuse he's most famous for
coining the phrase make love not war
back in the 1960s but he was also very
famous for an essay that he wrote called
repressive tolerance in which he
suggested that true tolerance can only
be achieved by preventing the full
flowering of Rights and if there are too
many rights all that means that you're
reinforcing hierarchies of power because
all you're doing is allowing people who
are bad to speak those people who are
bad are in charge of the system and
therefore you have to stop them from
speaking in order that the system can be
overturned so you actually need is a
repressive tolerance that is to say
tolerance of opinions from the left but
note
of opinions from the right and this is
what's happening on social media
platforms right now and they're starting
with people who are who are by all rules
bad right there starting with people at
YouTube by the way they like they just
ban for example Richard Spencer they're
starting with people who everybody
agrees our garbage and then they're
moving very quickly into the realm of
people who are edgy but not Richard
Spencer okay and that that is it that is
where they are moving so read it's a new
policy begins with the first world that
requires users to consider the human it
says remember the human reddit is a
place for creating community and
belonging not for attacking marginalized
or vulnerable groups of people now again
that is so vague that is virtually
meaningless except it just means we now
have an excuse to ban anyone we want
because what does it mean they don't
mean you're gonna see something overtly
racist about black Americans for example
which again I understand that being
banned what they mean is that if you say
anything like there's a person who's
just ban on Twitter for saying men are
not women that's the second person I
know who's been banned for saying men
are not women well I hate to break it to
you but men are not women is that
attacking a marginalized or vulnerable
group of people saying men are not women
like the the the vagueness of the policy
is where the death of free speech lies
at least in the culture at least in the
culture and again I'm perfectly happy to
make the distinction between the culture
and the legal but as I say the culture
predates illegal and as the culture
degrades the legal will quickly follow
so what is the latest excuse for this
why is this all happening right now it's
been down the way for a while right I
mean I've been talking about this on
college campuses since probably ten
years I was doing speeches on the death
of free speech on college campuses way
back in 2015 but it's broken down the
surface again obviously because the
black lives matter protest so why why
does black lives matter have to be an
attack what why is that being used as a
way to restructure America's culture of
rights in a great variety of ways right
the idea is that why let's put this way
why is canceled cultural rising at the
same level as the adherence and
attention to black lives matter these
should not be apart from one another
right you could separate them you could
you could separate those things
right you could and that would be a
that'd be a worthwhile thing you could
take black lives matter and also people
are allowed to express their opinion
right they don't have to be tied
together in other words but they are
tied together why are they tied together
because the idea is if you uphold the
system of rights that allows for people
to speak in ways you don't want you're
reinforcing hierarchies of power and
therefore the rights have to be shut
down parroting this message in a rather
sophisticated way and senator Elizabeth
Warren from Massachusetts so yesterday
Warren went to the the well of the
Senate and she explained it was not
enough to be not racist you have to be
anti-racist I'm gonna explain what she
means by this and why this sort of
language is deliberately vague and also
the amount of me the meaning that it
does carry is just wrong it is morally
wrong here is what Elizabeth Warren has
to say about racism being race conscious
is not enough it never was
we must be anti-racists removing the
names symbols displays monuments and
paraphernalia that honor or commemorate
the Confederacy and anyone who
voluntarily served it from military
property is in the broader scheme only
one step toward addressing systemic
racism in our society but it is an
important step okay so what does she
mean by anti-racist okay there's a new
language that we haven't heard until the
past few years right it used to be that
there was racist and there was not
racist because racist was to
discriminate what was eight was a point
of view on human beings that was you
were either it or you were not right the
idea was that you were racist if you
believed that people were inherently
inferior on the basis of race that was
the definition of racism and then you
were you're not racist if you don't
believe that in the same way that you
were either religious or you're not
religious right there were three cat
let's take religious as a good
counterpoint hey you're religious you
believe in God and then there was not
religious which is I don't really I'm
not I don't believe in God that she's
not my thing
and then there was anti religious which
is you spend all your time you spend all
your time fighting the religious right
you're Richard Dawkins and all your time
fighting the religious and so there are
three categories now the same thing
could be true in terms racism right you
could be racist which is evil you can be
not racist in which case you don't
believe in racism you think that it is
wrong and then it could be quote-unquote
anti-racist and presumably that would be
like professional activists what members
the left have now done is they've
collapsed the two categories so
instead of three you now have two
categories the categories are you are
either racist or you are anti races
there's no such thing as not racist
right this is the this is what elizabeth
warren is saying this comes really
courtesy oh that mmm Kennedy is a very
very radical writer on these issues
he has redefined the term racism to
really mean that if you believe that
individual human action is not a
reflection of systems then you are a
racist and so you have to tear down the
systems in order to affect the
individual human action he actually says
I mean he has made the contention
effectively I'm quoting Robyn D'Angelo
here the the author of the crappy book
white fragility
she says that kandi has argued that if
we truly believe that all humans are
equal disparity and condition can only
be the result of systemic discrimination
so in other words if there is one group
of people and they're poorer than
another group of people the only
possible reason that could happen the
only possible reason that could happen
is because of discrimination and in fact
if you see two individuals and one of
those individuals makes a bad decision
and does something wrong and has a worse
life another person doesn't do that it
is not they made individual bad
decisions they're both the products of
the system the system itself has been
discriminatory and subtle and evil ways
and that is why they are not ending with
equality of outcome and Abram Kenney
basically says this out loud
right he says in his book how to be an
anti-racist which is basically the text
book from which Warren is quoting he
says one either believes problems are
rooted in groups of people as a racist
or locates the root of problems in power
and policies as an anti-racist now
notice the false binary there there is a
third choice problems are located in the
individual but individuals don't
necessarily measure out equally across
all various racial groups because if you
took literally any group of people in a
room and you drew a line down the middle
of the group of people forget about race
just statistically speaking it would not
be equal an outcome in any way any room
in the world you take a line drawn
randomly down the middle of the line it
will not be equal people on the other
sides of the room because again when you
aggregate individuals there are always
differences this is just basic stats
okay this isn't there's nothing to do
with race but according to mm kandi if
you if every individual does not end up
with the same outcome then you can blame
the system and the system is racist and
if you don't fight the system you're not
an anti-racist so he says and either you
believe that but you can never believe
that problems are rooted in individual
behavior which could be the result which
could be disproportionately affecting a
group of people because of a culture
that exists in a particular community
that kind of culture doesn't
my culture does not exist in this view
of the world basically either its groups
of people until you're racist because
you believe groups of people are
inferior not the culture not the people
in a particular group just
proportionally asking in a certain way
because that happens statistically no
matter which group you look at as Thomas
SOLAS pointed out right it's either the
groups or it's the system and there is
no third option so you're either a
racist or you're anti-racist and if
you're anti-racist you have to tear down
the system from the inside if you have
to tear down the system from the inside
to be an anti-racist that means shutting
down all of these systems Homer the
culture of rights free speech free
expression he's all must be torn down in
the name of building a new tolerant
better world but that is the goal here
that is what they're talking about and
as Kennedy says one either allows racial
inequities to persevere as a racist or
confronts racial inequities as an
anti-racist but he means racial
inequalities he means any inequality is
an inequity he openly says this he says
any inequality is a reflection of a
racist system and if you don't fight the
system then you are you're not
anti-racist and if you're not
anti-racist you're not fighting the
system you are by definition racist
because remember there's a binary there
is no third category of not racist it
doesn't exist
that is what elizabeth warren is talking
about that is why the quantum quote
anti-racist movement driven by people
like Robyn D'Angelo and Abram candy that
is why they're pushing for the
destruction of the system and it's why
you are seeing the the push for that
movement existing at the same time as
much more censorship that is why they
don't have to be linked but that is why
they are one okay we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content including all the covin stuff
that I didn't get to and plenty of more
material go check us out over a daily
wire.com and go get a copy of my book
how to destroy America in three easy
steps at daily we're calm at /bin
otherwise we will see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show the ben shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel Whitehouse key technical
producer Austin Stephens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
Tsai events audio is mixed by Mike core
Amina hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20/20
public health experts lock us down again
a wealthy couple brandishes guns against
rioters and the supreme court burns
conservatives yet again check it out on
the michael noland show
[Music]
you